the human body is made up of different
tissues each with a specialist function
let's zoom into the liver
tissues are made up of cells specialized
to perform different functions let's
look inside this liver cell
within each cell are specialized
structures and compartments called
organelles the genome is found within an
organelle called the nucleus
the genome is packaged into structures
called chromosomes
there are 23 pairs of chromosomes
including two chromosomes that determine
your sex
women have two x-chromosomes men one X
chromosome and one Y chromosome
each chromosome is a length of DNA cord
up tightly to create structures called
chromatin loops
when we look closer at these loops we
can see the DNA is wrapped around
proteins known as histones to form
structures called nucleosomes
DNA itself is a double helix like a
twisted ladder it is made up of four
letters or bases called adenine cytosine
guanine and thymine a C G and T
a always pairs with T and C always pairs
with G the order or sequence of these
letters of DNA carry the instructions
for how a cell behaves and functions
specific sections of the DNA called
genes Co the instructions for producing
molecules the human genome contains
about 23,000 genes you can think of the
genome as an encyclopedia and the
chromosomes as the books that make up
the set if you were to print out all 3
billion letters of the human genome you
would make 120 books